well if we have all of these potential
issues and problems in the world of
crypto with different icos and the like
the natural question is what's the
regulatory structure that might address
these questions
that's a problem
if you stop it if you think about the
financial regulatory structure in the
united states
it was constructed primarily in the
1930s
as a result of the different regimes
that we put in place to address the
problems that were created by the great
crash of 1929
now there are great debates about how
you regulate crypto but about the only
thing that everybody agrees on
is that when congress adopted this
regulatory regime in the 1930s they
weren't thinking about crypto
that was not on their minds
so it doesn't come as much of a surprise
that the regulatory regime we have in
place the statutes that we have are not
well suited to the challenges that are
raised by crypto
regulators have to pound square pegs
into round holes all the time here
because they find new concepts they find
new ideas and they find precedent in
regulations that were never designed to
address these now this problem
intriguingly exists on three very
distinct levels
we've got the federal government the
united states
we they've have the individual states
which have their own regulatory regimes
and we then have international
regulation because remember much of the
crypto exists in a stateless form that
can be addressed and taken into and out
of the system in britain in malta in
korea and in the united states let's
just look at the united states system
that's hilaciously complex in and of
itself
first question
when is crypto a security
well if crypto is a security then you've
got to register with the sec or find an
exemption
if you should register and if you didn't
then you've got that registration put
that i talked about
if you lie in your white paper and if
you say that our tokens are going to
operate in a certain way and if you look
at the code in the token and what you
realize it doesn't operate in the way
that it's described well that's
potentially fraud and you're then
potentially subject to securities
enforcement action by the sec and by
private party litigants and also
every fraud violation of the federal
securities law is potentially a criminal
violation which opens you up to various
exposures by the department of justice
there's then the possibility that the
crypto can also be a commodity
subject to regulation by the commodities
futures and trading commission now as a
practical matter courts have already
ruled that crypto is a commodity but as
long as the crypto stays crypto it's
just the thing whatever it is the cftc
regulation isn't onerous
it's when you start trading derivatives
on the crypto that the cftc tends
typically to become much more important
so if you have futures for example on
bitcoin or options on bitcoin or you
create swaps on bitcoin those are
situations where you really do have to
worry about cftc involvement
then there's fincen regulation all right
this is a fraud
anti-fraud set of requirements
designed to protect against money
laundering and other forms of corrupt
behavior these are requirements that you
know your customer that you put into
place anti-money laundering regimes and
this is run through the fincen group in
the department of treasury that's
another whole set of regulations that
you need to think about
if that isn't enough we have our friends
at the internal revenue service
the irs is clear that transactions in
crypto
are taxable
and if you don't keep appropriate
records if you don't know how much you
paid for your crypto and how much you
got paid when you sold it you're going
to be potentially violating federal tax
law and also state tax law by not
reporting any income that you may have
made on the bitcoin that you bought for
25 cents that's now worth 6 thousand
dollars
last there's the federal trade
commission the federal trade commission
has a wide set of rules
involving
fraudulent statements in
advertising in the promotion of various
goods and services and it's easy to
observe that if something isn't a
security under the federal securities
laws but false claims are made about it
well then it's going to violate the
federal trade act
so
if you have a situation where there are
lies that are being told and there's
good reason to believe that there are
lots of lies being told
even if you're successful in arguing
that i'm not lying about a security
that doesn't mean that you haven't
violated the law all right you can wind
up being in trouble with the federal
trade commission and you can have
exposure there as well
now
if liability the federal level isn't
sufficiently interesting you also have
potential liability at the state level
each of the 50 states has their own
securities law and if you don't qualify
for exemptions at the federal level you
can then wind up in trouble at the state
level
so you can wind up being sued under
california law and under federal law and
under texas law and under massachusetts
law if it turns out that you wind up
with the sale
that violates the law in all of those
jurisdictions
in addition states have money
transmitter rules to the extent that
your crypto acts as though it's
transmitting money between locations you
may have to get money transmitter
licenses and you then may have to visit
each one of the states in which you're
doing business in order to get a money
transmitter license
and if you aren't totally exhausted
about the legal issues that arise simply
at the federal and state level in the
united states
recognize that your crypto may be
available worldwide
china has its own set of regulations
japan has its own set of regulations
france has its own set of regulations
canada has its own set of regulations
the provinces in canada have their own
sets of regulations malta is trying to
build a regulatory system which is very
welcoming in this particular area and if
you really want to operate a compliance
system you've got to be on top of all of
these different regulatory regimes
because when you're operating in crypto
space
you're operating everywhere and nowhere
at the same time and you're potentially
subject to all of these different levels
of regulatory scrutiny